hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review i have a special treat
for you
uh headphone review a brand new one that
was announced today from dan clark audio
called the stealth
um
it's a
gorgeous looking headphone very uh
professional i would say sort of serious
um
and super comfortable these pads are
just as nice as you can get as far as
touching them and feeling them
um
they are expensive four thousand dollars
and hopefully by the time i'm done you
can see that uh they bring value unlike
many high-end headphones in that price
range that uh don't really perform and
uh hoping that you think they're great
but they're
they usually are not
anyway um
the uh
pads inside are quite comfortable quite
deep uh they're slanted so this angle
here is quite a bit deep the depth is
quite a bit more on this side than this
side so it moves nicely which
uh you know wraps your ears quite nicely
a little bit tricky to measure because
you can actually slide the headphone
forward and back and it maintains the
seal and response can change a little
bit but that also helps in really making
a good seal around your head and you can
see me uh sort of wearing them like this
they come with a selection of different
uh
cords that you can get for them um and
with different terminations i think
they're like six different ones uh the
one that i have is a balanced
output uh which i recommend if you have
a balanced amplifier
or better set differential amplifier
uh on this thing um
the headband is nicely stitched there's
one of these uh suspension ones uh you
sort of you know self-adjusts on you um
you know no headphone is completely
comfortable in that you never ever feel
them but this is one of the best you
know you sort of know that you're
wearing something around your ear but
quickly uh you forget about them
um i'm sure there'll be tons of other
reviewers going over the you know the
looks of it and features and what have
you um
you come to my channel and and i'll use
soundcloud website to know about
performance of of products so let's dig
into that um a little bit on the design
and you'll see why this becomes
important
there's a special feature on this called
amts
or
acoustic material
what does a ts stand for that i forget
acoustic metal
or something something
but let me tell you what
material is meta material is a generic
term for
any substance
that you can take and improve its
characteristics in specific area you can
change the characteristics in light
domain in our case we care about
acoustic domain and you can do things
with that material uh with that comp
with that design that you can never do
with just building it out of a solid
object in this case we have a very
complex
patterned
structure this this uh i don't know what
you want to call the baffle or diffuser
it performs multiple functions by
changing the these channels in here
it can be used to diffuse that sound it
can be used to filter sound it can be
used to get real resonances
multiple functions
needless to say they're very complex
things to design and tune and i think
dan clark said
it's taking them four years to design
this you sort of have infinite
possibilities so it'll take you forever
to make this thing work because of all
these
complicated structures i'm sure it's not
easy to
mold this it's probably machined out of
some material and
likely adds a lot to the cost in this
thing but what's great about is that
they have incredible flexibility in
tuning the sound of the headphone both
in frequency response but also dealing
with any issues that makes this
acoustically in a product
and i'll show you that later on
um recently i tested this kef ls 50
meter
which uses metamaterial the same way not
the exact same application but they use
it to get rid of the reduced amplitude
of the internal reflections when you
have a speaker that's ported you can get
resonance inside and then they come out
the back of the port and become like a
little crappy speaker
they were i think they managed to get 10
or 15 db more improvement than if they
used world's best absorbers in there um
so
uh advanced material advanced design
techniques and it's just wonderful to
see it come to uh consumer products in
in multiple ways
a little bit on sizes on weights this is
obviously uh you know it's a large
headphone comes on a little bit on the
heavier side 415 grams although i did
not
feel that it was heavy there's some
giants in here
um that are quite a bit heavier in
general i'm tolerant of the weight of
headphones i do woodwork in other
projects and i wear helmets and safety
gear so uh maybe a little bit unusual in
that regard but still these are very
very comfortable uh uh talking about
size um i was amazed that it comes in
this little uh case when i first got it
i thought they sent me the wrong
headphone i was like wow a 4 000
headphone this must be a mistake send me
something small but it actually folds
very very neatly into this little case
so it's just portability taking a tune
for a work and what have you it's just
wonderful
it's not some giant contraption some
headphones look like they're massive
speakers on each side of your head and
they don't fold a lot of
care has gone into making these things
compact and and
you know easy to store
the best news uh comes uh in this one
graph and it really tells ninety percent
of the story um
wherever i've shown this preference
graph that comes from research in dash
blue that says uh
this is a response that you get if you
have a really good set of uh
speakers that have measurably flat on
axis response in anechoic chamber then
you put it in a in a good room and then
you add some amount of bass boost to it
because that's what they
found out harman found in control
listening tests that people like a bit
more bass boost so you get this and if
you heavily filter that frequency
response of that speaker you get the
smooth graph in blue
um there are i never get a headphone
that that matches this response uh some
come close but they they still have
deviations this uh stealth 10 clark
stealth headphone i don't know if i
mentioned the name of the headphone
before it's got the stealth um
that it matches this you know as
perfectly as headphone measurements can
every time i wiggled it and moved it
around on the fixtures some of these
curves change and everything so
headphone measurements are like
plus minus 20 30 percent as far as
accuracy these little peaks and valves
you see can be changed indeed you can
see one channel is a little bit more
than the other and what have you um
but you know generally i consider this
right on the target with the exception
of a hump in here that they put in on
purpose um
the uh you know when you a lot of
headphones are deficient in in high
frequencies and i suspect some people
may find that the headphone may be too
bright if you you know match this target
even though i think it's perfect adds to
the spatial qualities of the headphone
um
i think either they worried or they
thought that they better add a little
bit of warmth to it in here it's very
mild very small and you can just put a
filter in there if you want to get rid
of it uh on this thing but uh otherwise
you know this is as good as it gets with
half phone measurements so uh what this
means is that you don't need
equalization and i'll go over that in
the subjective listening
part of this test uh and a lot of people
you know talk about not having access to
eq on special ios devices where there is
no good way of installing an eq uh
app eq filter anywhere in the system and
in other platforms is work to figure out
you know where you deploy eq this
headphone based on this measurement says
it doesn't need equalization most
startling is to watch it look at it as a
relative curve if you subtract the
frequency response from the preference
you can see in here how closely we hug
the zero curve in here
you try to find a speaker that's flat to
20 hertz and below you're not going to
find any reasonable speaker
you know that goes that low yet we're
down here and then some and then yes we
have one or two db here and there but
again remember the measurements are you
know approximate like this cancellation
always happens because of the
measurement fixture it's just
on your ear just the nature of the
animal but if you look over here it's
just extremely close to our target
response
i actually received two samples of this
headphone i got an earlier sample that
had incredibly low
distortion these curves were all
squashed way down here um but they had
to make a tuning fix to it and
when i got the second sample
the the uh
they brought some of the base
frequencies down and when they did that
this as a percentage uh shots up shut up
a little bit but if you go way out here
where our hearing is incredibly
sensitive in two to
five kilohertz i measured it and the
distortion is point zero zero nine
percent it was actually point zero zero
eight percent in the first sample and if
you convert that to cyanide which i
measure for electronic devices that's 81
db it was 82 db in the other sample
and remember unlike electronics where my
analyzer is far lower distortion than
the devices that i'm measuring
here the we're using a measurement
microphone to measure the distortion of
of the uh
drivers the measurement microphone is
actually a little speaker itself so it
has distortions and companies never
specify that distortion it can be they
spec it up to a very high amount that it
could be so here we're seeing the sum of
the the two uh components adding
together
and still winding up with 81 db so what
is the microphone adding i don't know
maybe 1db 3d b5 dv8 db i don't know but
whatever we're measuring here is way
north of addb
in addition when we measure the harmonic
distortion when they get so small they
get buried in noise acoustic nodes that
exist in my room when i'm measuring
things so
this number is is
is better than we think so a lot of
people walk around say hey at best your
speakers on headphones or 50 db or
whatever
know that we could probably get close to
90 db or even more and this is at 94 db
spl this is not as a at a you know
whisper sound uh non-linearity drop like
a rock with volume so if you're
listening at 90 or 85 db
yeah this distortion is just going way
way way down uh potentially could be you
know distortion less or very close to
110 db at lower volumes i can't measure
them but
again because of the acoustic noise
let's just do we need a quiet anechoic
chamber to measure it but just amazing
amounts of
performance here look at when i go to
even
114 db spl the curving green and it
still barely budges from this just shows
you how that it hasn't climbed this
non-linear portion
of distortion even at those peaks uh you
know between the frequency response and
distortion you know that this is just a
very very very clean and transparent
headphone
we can also look at this at decibels
this is the playback level
of the headphone is the frequency
response is squashed because the scale
is much larger over here and look at
what happens from
about 100 hertz up the distortion is
just this constant amount that's
frequency independent and is so low
whenever you have peaks in here usually
means there's a resonance it's actually
not a distortion that means that it's a
you play a fundamental but then it
creates harmonics but if there's a
resonance the harmonics get amplified so
you see these spikes in here there's
none of that in here and this this is
just so controlled shows incredible
attention to uh optimization for
resonances and and other means of
distortion in here and you can see the
gap in here is at least 80 db which is
what our sine add was was showing us
over here so this is our playback level
and this massive gap and what distortion
there is the second harmonic which tends
to be masked more than third harmonic
third harmonic is another 10 or 15 db
even lower than that so
very very clean
um group delay i measure it uh it's been
a puzzle till now of you know whether if
you have uh whether this fuzziness that
oftentimes i see over here
is a good thing or bad thing there was a
theory that maybe that provided some of
the spatial effects as you'll see this
this headphone spec has great special
effects it has nothing in here um my
theory of why group delay gets messed up
is that you have more than one sound
source and if you have two sound sources
that mix together some phase cancels
some ad and everything and causes
messiness
and those secondary so the driver is one
source but the second resources are
other parts of the driver and the
headphone resonating becoming their own
little speakers and they all mix and and
mess up the phase response so this is
another sign that this the stealth is
designed so well to have essentially
none over here these deep nulls in here
again are just cancellations that we get
because of our ear and and the
fixture mimics that uh on this thing
a company suggested that i run a uh
impulse test i tend to not run it
because trying to figure out what's
audible here what's not is it's
challenging um but i ran it anyway and
i'll run it in the future and see where
we are but
uh we're seeing here that just the
transient response is superb because it
it settles in less than one millisecond
so this is one millisecond mark whoops
sorry you can't see the bottom of my
curve so this is one millisecond this is
zero we can see that the pulse got
activated somewhere in a quarter of a
millisecond and it it did his thing and
then it comes back and it settles it's
got two or three a little bit of ringing
and boom is settled so probably half a
milliseconds it took or millisecond
depending on how much of this you want
to count
for it to settle so those of you fans of
transient response and want to look at
that and
draw conclusions you can
um this is a low impedance headphone as
planar magnetics tend to be they're
basically
resistors
and uh that's flat response which means
that it won't if you have a high
impedance headphone amplifier uh its
frequency response won't change but if
you have a high impedance headphone
amplifier you're going to lose a ton of
power inside the headphone amplifier
very little of it will get to the
headphones so don't do that don't go
stick a tube amp in front of this with
high impedance um
as far as the sensitivity
it's not very sensitive the average in
here for all the headphones i've
measured almost 60 headphones is 167
millivolts it takes to
get it to 94 db sbl and you need three
times as much in here oops sorry my
window that i'm looking at is
um
got more columns in it that you can see
in the video sorry about that so the 549
in here you you're in the next bracket
in here to uh that requires more fun and
there's a crazy class up here that's
almost requires a you know speaker
amplifier um not out of line though just
about every headphone amplifier that i
recommend will easily drive it so don't
think you need something fancy or
special
my i use my rme adi 2 dac as the uh
test platform on my everyday listening
and while i had to turn it up to get the
volumes that i wanted it's it had no
trouble driving it so you just need a
well executed
headphone amplifier
directly driving it from
some phone or what have you because of
low impedance it'll probably work but
don't expect it to get very loud it'll
be very dynamic
now usually when i'm given a headphone
or speaker i go measure it first and
then i'll listen to them
in this case uh when i was sent the
headphone the question came from the
company kept coming back did you listen
to it did you listen to it i was like
okay i'll listen to it because you keep
asking about listening to that so i went
ahead and and uh
plugged in and listened and i thought i
used to you know figured i'd do that for
a couple of minutes and then go to
measuring it i got to tell you i could
not put down this headphone it sounded
so amazing so clean so dynamics the
tonality was just so perfect you think
that i know i get that when i cue other
headphones that are faulty that way
but the eq is not always exact and never
as as well-tuned as this is where you
know a company spends so much time
tweaking every part of that curve
and then just whether it's the low
distortion or my imagination or both i
can't tell you which
every few seconds i would say wow wow
wow and i'm just listening to the same
tracks i always listen to one testing
headphones
i just could not stop drooling over the
sound of this headphone i uh
you know i i don't impress easy because
i have i fortunate and and spoiled
enough to have a great audio system
myself and
get access to so much that gets sent to
me uh that you know my standard and what
i use every day is way up here so to
create a gap above that it's just
uh you know i didn't think that would
happen um
you know on this thing but it did it's
just
uh
amazing all around the transparency
superb just you turn it up no sign of
strain no sign of distortion and
just jewel worthy
sound
you know i could wax poetic forever but
if you've read my reviews you know that
i'm not good at that i put the data in
front of you and say judge
but i want to tell you that you know
subjectively this was just
incredible incredible incredible i used
an analogy you know first time i got an
oled tv and i watched the same videos
that i always watched and noticed
how much better the black levels were
and the contrast increased and the
fidelity was so much better the same
thing with a collection of music you
have when you get it you know headphone
uh the production device for the for the
first time that
that has even more dynamic range and
lower distortion and better compliance
the tonality all of a sudden
the experience is just transformative
on that front
so now four thousand dollars a lot of
money i grill the company left and right
on why is it so expensive and you know
will it come down in price and uh i
can't say i got a lot out of them uh
but these are handmade hand tweaked hand
assembled in san diego california so you
can imagine it's just hard to get
anything below a thousand dollars and
and make a living even at that um so
they had to pick a price and i think
it's fine where it is uh
yeah 99 percent of you won't get one but
hopefully becomes inspiration for both
the company and the rest of the industry
to start
building headphones to have this kind of
low distortion and and great tonality
and and importantly
paying homage to engineering proper
engineering and research the research
tells us what sounds good and
engineering tells us hey don't generate
resonances don't generate distortions
measure things distortions and and
abnormalities and sound and frequency
responses are 100 measurable uh there's
no excuse when we get a headphone i'll
suddenly find this incredible amount of
distortion and other sources uh of of
annoyance i mean you can't make a case
of those kinds of you know having three
other little speakers the way distorted
mixing sound with the direct sound that
comes out of the headphones so if you're
a competitor to dan clark i recommend
that you go get one if you're not into
headphones you're building speakers
you're building an audio system of any
sort you still should go buy the one of
these things and expensive to the
company because you want to know
what is a world-class
sound system that if it had been
speakers would be a few hundred thousand
dollars and you're hanging around your
ear you don't have the tactical tactile
feedback obviously of bass but you have
this deep bass that just is flat and
smooth and goes down to 10 hours and
lower that you know try to get a speaker
system with subwoofers or whatever to
get that kind of flat response with no
modal problems that i could get in the
room it's just not possible
when i listen to my reference tracks and
these are you know great tracks that
i've selected
it just brought out their beauty like
you would not believe and and i picked
those things because when i played my my
main system on my rovel salon two
speakers or 23 25 000 speakers
you know i get it does justice to them
there but here i think it just removes
the room and gives you even smoother
more higher fidelity experience
but obviously there's no tactile
feedback so i'm not giving up my stereo
system with speakers i want to feel the
music i'll go there but many times many
hours i'm sitting here at my desk
working and i want the best absolutely
best possible system and i want to learn
what the best possible sound system is
and this is it um
so
again if you're an audio company and you
know you got a few dollars in your
pocket because you have a real business
you owe it to yourself to go pick up one
of these things and and
listen to it then listen to the
if your speaker company then listen to
your speakers and see how they compare
to this this will show you
you know the pinnacle of sound
reproduction sense the tactical
tactile stuff but otherwise you know if
the sound is not as enjoyable as these
you know there's something wrong and
hopefully over time the
cost will come down
on these things and
we all get to have it at lower cost even
for me i'm a cheapskate when it comes to
spending money on audio these days i've
spent my money already once and i cringe
at spending four thousand dollars but
you gotta just so bow and say wow what
what great headphones um unfortunately
these are not a gift uh don't get to
keep up company made in the condition to
return them and so don't think i'm
saying all these things because somebody
gave me a four thousand dollar headphone
to keep uh they did not
it's going back to them it'll be a sad
day when when that happens so i want to
get this video out to you guys uh it's
uh 12 20 at night uh
20 minutes past midnight but i thought
it was important to give you my uh
personal uh words on this thing the
review has been out a few hours in text
but i thought i'd give you my video take
as well
okay
so hopefully
you found this video
useful and and see some clear
innovation happening in sound
reproduction
okay see you in a future video bye